as expected here's the statement from
the
owner of the washington nfl franchise
daniel snyder as this season concludes
bruce allen has been relieved of his
duties as president
of the franchise and is no longer with
the organization like our passionate fan
base i recognize we have not lived up to
the high standards set by great teams
coaches and players who have come before
us as we reevaluate our team leadership
culture and process for winning football
games i am excited for the opportunities
that lie ahead to renew our singular
focus and purpose of bringing
championship football back to washington
dc again that's owner daniel snyder
announcing
the
departure of bruce allen there was a
thought that maybe maybe bruce allen
would stay with the team in some
non-football capacity that's not going
to happen ron rivera according to ian
rappaport of the nfl
could be hired
as soon as today wow as the head coach
and because he counts as a minority
candidate they don't have to go through
the broader more extended search right
they can interview him they can hire him
on the spot and he may get it today also
urban meyer there's talk that he's going
to end up with the team in some capacity
and now that bruce allen has cleared out
there's spots in there yeah sure for
people to show up i just don't know
where a lifelong college football coach
fits with an nfl team other than as
coach that's a little peculiar to me now
he doesn't have an eye for talent
certainly but that's a different type of
talent when you're 17 18 years old and
evaluating that to make it work for a
college team as to comparing a 29 or 30
year old or you know grown men who have
been in the league for a while uh it is
a different evaluation but it makes
sense and i don't know i'm not shocked
by this bruce allen uh news there you go
no no no well we say
nbc sports washington yeah reported it
over the weekend it was going to happen
the only question is was alan going to
stay or was he going to go and watch for
him to potentially land with the rams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports